I'm Wayne indyke I'm the chief
projectionist here at the IMAX theater
at the Indiana State Museum we have the
largest screen in the state it's 60 feet
tall 84 feet wide and when we run IMAX
film The portions of the film that were
shot with IMAX cameras fill that screen
entirely we are thrilled to welcome all
of you here for the opening night of
Chris or no one's often timer
this is print number 25 of Oppenheimer
in IMAX film it arrived in 53 reels that
I spliced together over the course of
three days
the frame size is about that big it's
going about 350 feet per minute it goes
through a lot of film very fast it's a
massive experience and it's so much more
than what you're gonna see if you watch
it on TV at home